[Applause]
they came from all parts of the country
hundreds of people brought together by
the opposition party samadhi jana bala
vega to protest against increases in the
prices of essential goods
we don't have food no place to stay no
job is it only their family the
rajapaksas that should be nourished
that's why we are here guest's name is
pitine there is no gas no milk powder my
children are crying my gas finished a
day before yesterday and i cursed the
government so much
an estimated 90 billion dollars of debt
an economic slowdown and the pandemic
have hit sri lanka hard
a currency crisis has left it with
foreign reserves of just over 2 billion
dollars enough to pay for imports for
six weeks
that's left the country short of basic
goods and having to restrict imports
president gotaber rajapaksa declared a
state of emergency which had little
effect and the government has now
removed price controls on many food
items and other essential goods
but critics accuse it of failing to deal
effectively with the crisis
for the hundreds of people who have
rallied to the capital colombo today
there's one rallying call the crippling
costs of living and the government's
inability to control it
they say the government has ignored the
real plight of the people
the opposition says it's airing the
grievances of the people
many who cannot fend for themselves
we are
facing economic armageddon
it's an apocalyptic situation
the
people are suffering
due to
a variety of issues primarily
because of
male administration
authoritarianism
autocracy
while politicians seek to assure the
public many say that's not enough
and with so much hardship they
desperately need some relief
miner
al jazeera colombo